The DC Universe is broken.
Superman is lost.
Black Adam stayed in the red. Cyborg has been
silenced.
Wonder Woman has vanished into thin air.
And the Flash has gotten into so much trouble
that DC wishes he'd just run his way into
an entirely new timeline.
But there's still hope for the future, my
friends.
And the key to solving all of it?
Cartoons
Hello Internet!
Welcome to Film Theory, the show that wants
you to subscribe faster than the Flash.
Bet you can't do it and write your favorite
superhero down in the comments in less than
3 seconds.
Three, two.
Wait, you did it?
Dang, you are faster than a speeding bullet.
Well done.
Now, it might be difficult to remember, but
there was a time not too long ago when DC
was the top dog when it came to superhero
movies.
Remember The Dark Knight trilogy?
Those movies made over $2.4 billion at the
box office.
One of them was so good that when it wasn't
nominated for best picture at the Oscars,
the Academy literally changed their rules
to avoid anything like that ever happening again.
But in the following years…
Yeah…
Yeah. Not so much.
The DCEU, which officially started with Man
of Steel ten years ago, has been an absolute mess.
And that's not meant to be a judgment call
or measure of quality.
I mean, just as a point of fact, right now
there are three different Batmen and two separate
Jokers running around at the same time, and
that's just the tip of the iceberg.
Since the DCEU started, it's been a nightmare
of hiring, firing and rehiring multiple directors
for the same project.
Actors being let go brought back again, only
to be let go again.
There's been public fallout over bad behavior
by studio executives, constant cameos and
teases for films that will never happen while
completely finished movies are just outright canceled.
Meanwhile, you got star actors dealing with
felony allegations popping up like the worst
game of whack a mole ever.
And the only thing that's dropped further
than the quality of some of these things is
WB's stock price, which got so low that it
was basically sold for spare parts to the
guy who runs the Discovery Channel.
Gotta be honest here your loyal theorists,
as someone who grew up loving DC’s heroes
more than Marvel's, it's been really heartbreaking
to see this.
But now there's new hope.
Warner Brothers has brought on James Gunn,
writer and director of Guardians of the Galaxy,
The Suicide Squad and Peacemaker, to shepherd
their movies back to financial and critical success.
And, while he certainly has a long path ahead
of him to get the DC Universe back to where
it needs to be.
I think he can do it, provided he follows
my advice today.
That's right, loyal theorists.
Today I plan to give this new master of the
Universe a five point guide on how to make
a successful DC cinematic franchise.
And I'm not just pulling this from anywhere.
I have proof that these steps will work.
So put on your super suits and kiss your Martha's
goodbye.
Let's save ourselves a franchise, shall we?
Hey there theorists, future MatPat here, for
the second Film Theory in a row go figure.
So literally, just a couple of hours ago,
as I write this, James Gunn came out and did
a big presentation talking about DC's future
plans, announcing ten new projects for Gods
and Monsters, the so-called first chapter
of their big DC reboot.
Mind you, this is a couple of days after we
wrote and recorded this and got the audio
out to our editors.
James Gunn's announcement kinda came out of
nowhere.
Usually they preface this sort of stuff or
try to time it around big industry events,
but nope, this was him just dropping a big
ol’ promotional bomb in the middle of everyone.
So what I'm going to be doing now is laying
out my advice exactly as it was written, not
changing the script at all.
But then at the end of each section, I'm going
to pop back in to assess how Gunn seems to
be handling things going forward.
Does it look like he's taking our advice?
Is he ignoring it and doing his own thing,
or is he falling into the mistakes of his predecessors?
Let's just jump back into the theory and find
out.
Step number one, take care of your heavy hitters,
both in terms of characters as well as the
talent behind them.
In pop culture, DC’s characters have a pretty
strong brand identity.
Most people know who Superman, Batman, Wonder
Woman, Aquaman and the Flash are.
Heck, even Green Lantern.
So at least to start, your focus needs to
be on revitalizing most of the core cast with
strong movies or series.
It’s not to say that I don't think a Cyborg
or a Black Adam or a Birds of Prey can work
on screen.
But why would people go to see those if you
can't even get Superman right?
Right now, DC needs to rebuild the audience's
trust.
They need to let them know that they're delivering
fun, high quality movies consistently with
all the name brands that we know and love.
Then and only then will people start to come
out for the second stringers.
I mean, case in point, just look at Marvel
phase one.
You got to do your Captain Americas and Thor's
justice before anyone gives the talking tree
and sassy rabbit a chance.
The Marvel brand can carry smaller characters
now.
All that said, the other side of the coin
is after you've done a few of your core characters justice.
If a creative comes along and has an amazing
pitch for something more obscure, run with it.
You may end up making C-list characters like
Animal Man or the Doom Patrol into household names.
And we know that DC is capable of this.
Look no further than Shazam.
It had a great story with a likable tone and
a strong cast, and now you're seeing him enter
the cultural zeitgeist more and more.
Even more obscure; before The Suicide Squad,
no one had ever heard of a Peacemaker.
But now he's played by a world famous wrestler
and has his own popular TV show.
My mom has heard of Peacemaker.
Again, Marvel has routinely done this when
they didn't have the rights to their biggest
names like Spider-Man or the X-Men.
They looked at their second stringers.
The core Avengers cast used to be the guys
that cameoed in the Spider-Man cartoons.
Now they're all huge franchises of their own
right.
And I don't just mean Iron Man and Captain
America here either.
They've turned the Scarlet Witch, Shang-Chi,
Moon Knight and the Guardians of the Galaxy
into brands that are big enough to carry their
own films, TV shows and theme park rides.
Kevin Feige has gone on record saying that
when they're deciding which characters to
adapt, it doesn't matter how famous or popular
the character is in the comics, only that
there's great potential for a movie.
Story should always come first.
All right.
Future MatPat with the assessment.
So how's Gunn handling things?
Well, it kind of remains to be seen.
Though there was a big focus on projects like
the new iterations of the core cast with Superman
Legacy and the Brave and the Bold.
There was also a surprisingly large amount
of obscure stuff thrown in the mix.
Swamp Thing?
Booster Gold?
Still, I think Gunn understands that they
need to get their heavy hitters right, he
told Deadline in one of the interviews, Quote.
“One of our strategies is that we take our
Diamond characters - Batman, Superman, Wonder
Woman - and we use that to help prop up other
characters that people don't know.”
And thus we get ourselves Creature Commandos.
So in theory, IN SUPERHERO THEORY! he seems
to get it, But we'll see how things pan out.
Which leads me to my next piece of advice;
Number two: trust the source material.
The fans love these characters and they have
loved these characters for decades.
There's a reason for that, and it's your job
to understand why.
What is the core value of that character to
the audience?
And then once you understand what that is,
do not change it.
There are so many recent examples of people
using IP without any sort of respect for the
source material.
Isn't that right, Velma?
For instance, Superman, the symbol of truth,
justice and the American way.
Should not be destroying whole city blocks
or snapping necks in a gritty drama.
Or if he is, that needs to be the point.
That is the dramatic struggle.
That's the conflict that the movie has to
explore throughout its runtime.
The character who is determined to be purely
good, is suddenly forced into positions where
he has to question his own ethical line.
That? that is an interesting movie.
It's the superhero version of the trolley
problem.
Dig into that because it plays into what people
love about Superman.
His unironic, unspoiled sense of pure goodness
and hope.
Don't just leave it as some sort of footnote
to happen at the end of the film.
If you want an example of what not to do,
take a look at Netflix's The Witcher.
It started out great with Henry Cavill, a
beloved actor and fan of the material stepping
in to play the title character.
But things quickly devolved as the creatives
started changing parts of the Witcher mythos,
to the point that rumors started swirling
that the writers hated their source material.
That right there is what we call a big red
flag.
And the fan reviews for both Season two and
the spinoff Blood Origins reflect that.
Is it any wonder that Henry Cavill bowed out
of the franchise that he loved so he could
go work on a Warhammer adaptation?
He even released a public statement saying,
(mis)quote, “I promise to respect this IP
that we love.
I promise to bring you something familiar.”
Not a good look for the creative team over
at The Witcher, huh?
In short, audiences aren't dumb.
They can tell when something's made with a
genuine love for the IP.
So if you find out that your writer staff
can't be bothered to pick up and read some
comic books, then just stop what you're doing.
Stop it right there and find a project that
they are excited about or, you know, scrap
the whole team and get someone who actually
wants the project.
You know, a character that has some ridiculous
lore?
Sonic the Hedgehog, But both Sonic movies
have embraced that video game weirdness to
deliver movies that are in the top ten highest
grossing for the year.
They respected the source material.
Speaking of that Sonic lore, by the way, if
you're interested in just how crazy Sonic
lore gets and how the newest game's release
breaks all of it.
We just released a Game Theory about that
very topic.
Link is in the top right corner of the screen.
Make sure you watch that one after we're done
solving the DCEU’s problems.
Future MatPat back again, happy to say that
I think Gunn nails this point.
The new Superman project seems to be borrowing
from more hopeful stories, the Brave and the
Bold is bringing more of Batman’s very popular
family of characters onto the screen, and
embracing stranger parts of the obscure IP
they’re adapting, Awesome.
Even that Supergirl movie is adapting a really
new, really weird story that fans and critics
loved, borrowing more from stuff like John
Carter than Smallville.
On paper, everything here is looking great,
which makes a lot of sense.
I mean, we’re talking about a guy who made
a talking racoon, alien tree, and Polka-Dot
Man work on film.
If there was any one of these 5 points that
he was going to knock out of the park, it
was going to be this one.
Now back to the advice.
Point number three and this is a bit of a
corollary to what we just talked about.
If a character doesn't fit a tone, don't force
them into a movie with that tone.
Basically, you don't want to try to ram a
Superman shaped block through a Batman shaped
hole, despite both of them being superheroes,
the types of stories they tell aren't anywhere
close to the same Something I don't think
a lot of people understand about Marvel's
output is that they aren't superhero movies.
They're movies with superheroes in them. Sure.
And they do have consistent factors.
But “superhero” isn't the genre.
Instead, Marvel looks at their characters
and then writes stories about them in genres
that make sense.
To really explain what I mean.
Let's just take a look at three of the franchises
Captain America, Ant-Man and Spider-Man.
All three of these series have Marvel's trademark
quippy humor, costume design, art, direction,
all that jazz.
But the types of stories they're telling are
all very different.
Winter Soldier and Civil War are political
thrillers making commentary on serious social issues.
Both Ant-Man films are heist movies, featuring
Scott Lang breaking into somewhere highly
secure to either steal something or rescue
someone.
And both of these franchises are way different
from the Spider-Man movies, which are all
Gen-Z, John Hughes, coming-of-age films.
The stakes are different, the structures are
different, the genres are different.
So how does that apply to DC?
Well, Batman's historically done this well.
The Christopher Nolan Batman trilogy are crime
thrillers.
Matt Reeves’s the Batman leaned into the
noir elements of a detective story.
Both of them were dark and gritty and rightfully
so.
But the problem begins when you start to layer
that tone across a whole franchise.
Wonder Woman?
Shazam?
Superman?
They're not gritty characters, so trying to
layer them into gritty stories is going to
create tonal conflict.
This was arguably one of the biggest issues
with the early phases of the DCEU.
Zack Snyder's aesthetic was being applied
like a filter over everything.
The genre of those early movies was “Superhero/comic-book”
and nothing really more.
But if you look at the movies in the franchise
that worked the best: Shazam!
Wonder Woman, Aquaman and THE Suicide Squad,
they weren't afraid to break from the mold
and carve out their own tone.
Wonder Woman (the good one) was part period
war film, part mythological epic.
Aquaman borrowed a lot from old school adventure
movies like Indiana Jones and The Mummy, and
audiences loved both of those.
Ocean Man movie has drum playing octopus?
Awesome!
Kids superhero movie has YouTube humor?
Perfect!
Talking shark movie has giant alien starfish
enemy?
Cool!
Just because everyone in the DCEU shares the
collective world, it doesn't mean that everyone's
part in that world needs to share the same
tone.
You need to look at the characters that you're
working with and then make movies around them,
not force them into the movies that you're
trying to make.
So make an upbeat Superman action film with
a journalistic subplot, make a space cop action
drama with the Green Lantern, just give them
all room to breathe and do their own thing.
Future Matpat review time: DC’s approach
to this one seems perfect.
Not only are they letting stuff like the Batman
and Joker sit in their own worlds with their
own tone, they’re also carrying over the
only parts of the DCEU that people loved;
Aquaman, Wonder Woman, Shazam, and The Suicide
Squad.
Plus they are very clearly embracing different
tones in the new adaptations that they’re
bringing to the table.
They even had the same idea for that “True
Detective in Space” version of Green Lantern
we just pitched right there.
Great minds thinking alike, huh James?
Piece of advice number four, And this is a
big one: Take your time.
Take your time making the movies good.
Duh.
But also, more importantly, take your time
announcing what you're working on.
That way you can see what works, what audiences
react positively to, and what you need to
work on behind the scenes if something doesn't
pan out.
All without publicly embarrassing everyone
involved.
Seems obvious, right?
You would think.
But a lot of studios make this mistake.
See, the MCU had this weird marketing strategy
for a film franchise when it was still young.
They'd have Kevin Feige come out at ComicCon
and announce the entire next 3 to 5 years
of movies all at once.
At the time when they were still growing their
brand, it worked really well for them.
It got fans excited, which built up hype.
But this taught the other studios the wrong
lessons.
Everyone wanted a piece of the pie and so
they tried their best to start the next MCU
ASAP.
Universal might just be the best, worst example
of this that I can think of with their attempted
reboot of their classic monster movies under
the Dark Universe banner back in the mid 2010s.
They announced half a dozen movies mapped
out with a deep mythology's worth of lore.
They cast Hollywood superstars like Tom Cruise,
Johnny Depp, Angelina Jolie.
They even released a star studded cast photo
of the major players all in one place.
So you knew that they were serious about it.
Fun fact, by the way, none of those actors
were actually in the same room for this photoshoot.
They were just Photoshopped together.
Anyway, the one thing that Universal didn't
do in all of this?
Make sure the movies that launched the franchise
were actually worth watching.
Dracula Untold was a moderate financial success,
but was eviscerated by critics and fans.
And The Mummy, starring Tom Cruise?
It did even worse.
The most memorable thing about that movie
was the trailer they mistakenly uploaded without
any audio.
Yep. That was a real trailer uploaded by a real
major movie studio.
All in all, even with the exciting IP and
awesome star power they had lined up, Universal
did not take their time building up this IP,
and as a result, people looked at the Dark
Universe and said:
I'm not interested in that, at all.
DC did the exact same thing.
In 2014.
They announced ten movies for their new universe,
spearheaded by Zack Snyder, ranging from Wonder
Woman and Aquaman to Shazam! and Cyborg.
Some were as far away as six years.
The only problem with this, they didn't actually
wait to see how people liked the first couple of movies.
Cue the internal executives Scramble studio
interference, replacing directors, shifting
schedules, delays, cancellations and public
embarrassment.
All of them were self-inflicted wounds that
were totally avoidable.
Warner Brothers didn't need to go out and
announce ten movies.
They could have just gone with three or four,
seen how people liked the first stab at things
and then privately changed plans in the background
when it became clear that audiences weren't
clicking with the DCEU.
This is the one that makes future MatPat a
little worried.
I'm skeptical about the fact that so many
projects just got announced this week, another
ten in total, which is just like that initial
wave of DCEU announcements.
That being said, I suppose they're not completely
starting from scratch here.
They are bringing what worked from the DCEU
over into this new universe, so at least they're
starting on a positive note.
Plus, I also found this quote where Gunn said
that they're willing to delay movies if the
scripts aren't 100% ready.
Now, I would hope that this would normally
be the default in Hollywood, but looking at
blockbusters over the last decade, clearly
not.
But I wouldn't be getting too far ahead of
myself because piece of advice number five:
Don't have a long term plan.
I’m not kidding.
Don't meticulously plan out the new universe.
So you know exactly what's supposed to happen
and when.
I know it sounds counterproductive, but I
promise that you'll regret doing this.
By having so much of your franchise laid out.
You don't give yourself room to maneuver.
If something changes, if a new character pops
up that you want to insert into the franchise
or a writer comes along to offer you a great
story that otherwise doesn't fit.
Again, you can learn from Marvel here.
And the big example I'm going to point to
is Captain America Civil War.
This was a huge movie for the franchise.
Basically Avengers 2.5, featuring the culmination
of a ton of stories and setting up a ton of
others for the future.
From the outside looking in, it might have
seemed like they planned the whole thing from
the start, but they didn't.
Civil War wasn't even the original pitch.
The writers wanted to adapt a different Captain
America story called MadBomb, but Feige didn't
think that it went big enough.
So things pivoted to Civil War.
And even then there were multiple versions
of Civil War floating around with and without
Spider-Man.
Since Marvel was busy negotiating over the
character with Sony, and if they hadn't come
to an agreement there?
Ant-Man would have switched sides to become
Team Iron Man, thereby changing his entire
character arc in all the future movies.
But Marvel just decided to go with the flow
and did what worked in the moment.
Now, that's not to say that you shouldn't
have a vague idea of what to do or where your
story is going.
You 100% should, so you can build to it.
Marvel did exactly that in Hulk and Iron Man
1, teasing the Avengers initiative because
they knew that eventually they were going
to have a crossover.
They just didn't have what was going to happen
in The Avengers laid out.
And then the Avengers movie itself teased
Thanos, because again, Marvel knew that eventually
they'd want him to be a big bad, but writing
out how exactly they were going to get their
beat for beat? That's no bueno.
Seriously, did you know that for a while nobody
at Marvel had decided where the Infinity Stones
were? Or even what was and wasn't an Infinity
stone.
True story.
According to tweets from James Gunn himself,
when they first shot Guardians of the Galaxy,
the Infinity Stone in the movie was Red, the
color of the reality stone.
But in post it had to be changed to the Purple
Power stone because Marvel had decided after
the fact that the red one would be coming
from Thor the Dark Worlds aether.
Heck! They didn't even know why Thanos wanted the Stones to kill half the universe until they
sat down to write the script for Infinity
War.
I mean, if you need any more proof of their
lack of a plan, they featured the Infinity
Gauntlet in Odin's vault as early as phase
one.
But plans changed…
And it was retconned, which, when you think
about it, is kind of funny because this then
is a fake of a gauntlet that hadn't even been
built yet.
But you know what?
I don't hate it because we got a better movie
franchise out of it.
Final future MatPat review: I'm not too worried
there.
Even though they did talk about plans to have
characters appear in multiple projects, Gunn
didn't come out and announce a giant crossover
event that everything's leading up to.
It seems like they're just going to go with
the flow for now, which I think is the smart option.
That said, there is still one final big thing
that I want to point out to Gunn here.
So that is a lot of advice.
But here's the biggest twist of them all.
DC already has the perfect blueprint to model
parts of this new cinematic universe from,
and it's followed basically all of this advice.
It was called the DC Animated Universe.
If you grew up with DC in the nineties and
aughts, you definitely recognize this franchise.
It's where a lot of the iconic modern portrayals
of DC characters originated.
Kevin Conroy's Batman, Mark Hamill's Joker.
Those were these versions of Batman and Joker
before they made their way into the animated
films and Arkham video games.
So how does the DCAU follow my advice?
Let's go point by point.
Firstly, yes, they knew that the heavy hitters
were important.
They started this universe out with Batman
and then they grew into a Superman show before
they had the two of them team up in Justice
League.
But what else did they do?
Well, an awesome new character named Static
came along in the comics and they jumped at
the chance to adapt him with a creative team
that were excited to tell his stories.
And when the really weird but really cool
idea for a cyberpunk Batman spin off came along?
They made Batman Beyond.
They also let less important characters shine
in the Justice League shows.
Seriously.
Hawkgirl, The Question, Etrigan the Demon,
all minor characters that had leading roles,
episodes, even entire story arcs devoted to
them.
Not only that, but they adapted these characters
in ways that didn't pigeonhole them into tones
that didn't fit.
They let Batman have a darker, more noir tone.
Superman was more upbeat and sci fi, Static
Shock didn't feel the same as Batman Beyond,
which also didn't feel the same as Justice
League.
Fourthly, they took their time building the
world.
Batman The Animated Series, was first released
in 1993.
Superman didn't get his spin off until 1996,
and Justice League didn't come along until
2001.
And finally, though DCAU head honcho Bruce
Timm might have had ideas on where to take
the universes story the creators didn't plan
beyond what seasons and shows had already
been greenlit.
They didn't go into Batman in the early nineties,
mapping out where their Justice League spin
off in 2005 was going to take them.
Listen, DC James, you guys have a golden opportunity
here to take some of the most beloved characters
and IP in the world and make something really
meaningful.
It won't be easy, but exactly how to do it
is right in front of you.
All you need to do is follow my advice.
And just go watch some great old cartoons.
In the meantime, though, if you want to see
my last piece of advice that I gave to DC
that they chose not to follow, check out my
theory on how they should have used the Snyder
cut to fix the DCEU timeline.
Or if you want to see what Batman villain
DC should have set up with The Batman.
Check out my theory about Hush and the Joker.
Don't forget to subscribe for more superhero
theories coming your way soon.
And as always, remember, it's all just a theory.
A FILM THEORY!
Aaaaaaaaaand cut.